toujours pas touché dans
[Musique]
ou la gadoue la gadoue bombe à fred
notre danseuse nous a donné rendez vous
dans ce parc
ne me demandez pas pourquoi je n'en sais
rien on va le découvrir ensemble
[Musique]
waouh
quel accueil
tellement gracieux tu fais avec une
telle facilité
merci à dieu sait quoi la danse aérienne
et vêtements alors la danse aérienne en
fait ce sont sept sont des disciplines
qu'ils utilisent tous que nous on
appelle dans notre jargon les verticaux
c'est à dire toutes les disciplines qui
sont suspendus accrochez peut y avoir
des tissus des cocons décor des trapèzes
trapèze danse centrale gymnastique que
le ciri dynamique dans cirque et
escalade
c'est ça je fais tout était tout petit
cheville comme ça ouais les gars y a des
droits mais tu vas voir tu vas essayer
on va les répéter on va faire une fleur
j'essayais tu as essayé d'aimer ou ça au
garage
ok allez suis moi je te suis allé bien
[Musique]
l'incroyable ce lieu fremm c'est un
espace partagé de travail on est onze
créateurs et artisans à avoir des boks
ici et à s'entraîner moi tu vois c'est
là je répète ici
ce que j'ai posé un fret qui maîtrise la
danse aérienne donc je me la joue mais
au feat donc si vous ne trouvez
maladroit de la trilogie patrie
gracieuse ces volontaires lautner c'est
volontaire
[Musique]
donc la séance et de t'accompagner c'est
ça et toi tu vas essayer avec moi ici
ok très bien moi je suivre des consignes
dans un premier temps on va voir si tu
arrives à te renverser le renverser oui
très simple et regarde tu vas juste
faire ça et si l'aïe et revenir ça
s'appelle la bouille
j'ai fait ça toute mon enfance
donc on s'attrape comme ça c'est mal
parce que c'est assez élastique
on s'attend pas à ça d'autres fois avoir
une bonne prise en main je crois ouais
je tire c'est mes bras essayez de faire
une boule renversé tu reviens donc pour
sa foire des beaux abdos tu vas voir
aller là bas vers l'arrière et
[Rires]
impressionnant pour sa personne comme ça
mais c'est assez déstabilisant
au début oui parce que en fait là et
rien tu utilises l'oreille interne avec
ton équilibre et non plus le pied
le rapport au sol donc à un moment il
faut juste laisser à les embarquer et
voilà oubliez le rapport au sol
l'essence va lancer la première fois
c'est difficile en fait je ne balance
pas de cet avis va tout en douceur c'est
ça bon réveil à l'oreille
c'est sa superbe au super et reviens tu
vas voir on va essayer de faire une
montée tu as commencé avec une fac en
sociologie qu'est ce qui t'a donné envie
de changer complètement de voir et ben
écoute quand j'étais en fac justement
j'ai rencontré les arts du cirque et a
été séduite voilà c'est ça et j'ai
décidé d'en faire mon métier et sexy
métier que tu as voyages à travers le
monde
exactement avant de venir de
sédentariser ici à saint nazaire
pourquoi le choix de cette ville tu mens
tu as d'origine je suis nantaise
d'origine monteux santé terre est si
c'est ça c'est ça me plaisait de revenir
ici et la ville est très sympa tu as
créé la compagnie d'un festival
j'ai entendu dire j'ai ouï dire que tu
l'écris même une un bac cirque en tout
cas tu aimerais pour là je vais je
travaille sur un projet en fait de
montages d'école du cirque
oui ici sur saint nazaire et
effectivement je suis intéressé pour
travailler sur des options sire que des
options en voie de professionnalisation
nat maintenant je vais te montrer autre
chose
regarde alors l'idée ça va être de te
suspendre tu vois d'abord au départ on
met son poids dans les tissus plutôt que
de repousser le sol comme ça on met tout
son poids
l'idée c'est de mettre ton poids et
ensuite tu va poser ton pied à
l'extérieur soulevé genou poitrine et
l'autre va venir deux sous et dessus et
tu repousses sud grandis tu vois regarde
là j'ai décollé du sol
je suis suspendu aléatoire très simple
je vais t'aider
j'ai bien compris qui a le flex genou
feutrine c'est ça aille plus haut plus
en plus c'est l'acte ça y est c'est
super blonde tu aimeras c'est ça encore
roche est fière de moi c'est bien peu
magnifique
ça fait plaisir quand même bien c'est ce
qu'on fait à la première séance regard
je te montre autre chose
là tu vas venir mettre tes genoux à
l'intérieur t'asseoir du remonte le
bassin tu veux être ton pieds cambrés
regarder oui bien sûr mais évidemment je
reste dans cette position je crois on
essaye oui il y en essayent alors
atteint le pied à l'extérieur le petit
cercle ensuite dessous de ce sujet c'est
bien de mettre le qui suivrait bien
viens avec tes deux jeunes arrières
d'ailleurs voilà les mains au niveau des
yeux à demi mot les yeux un poil plus
voilà et maintenant tu vas te cambrai
cambridge et on bassin vers le plafond
adam et les le voilà comme ça voilà à
les repousser repousse son bassin et
grandit toi c'est ça regarde si et si et
là ça fait râler cambre grande roue
continue c'est super héros
fred est ce que tu es fier de moi je
suis super fière de toi c'était très
beau ce que je dois un petit spectacle
maintenant fred tu as envie j'aimerais
bien ok vous voir tout cela à l'oeuvre
elle va écoute d'accord je demande à
sauf et puis on se fait un duo notre dû
k
[Musique]
oui
austère
[Musique]
séguin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
fred est encore un bel exemple de ces
acteurs du territoire qui font vivre
leur région à travers leur passion
[Musique]